que era en el año 36, 36 mil dólares
más que hoy 100 millones de dólares
¿Qué es en la foto?
Esa es una foto de mi querida señora Paula Faschul
cumpliendo 50 años
casados
¿Cuándo fue tomada esa foto?
Esa foto
fue tomada
cinco años y medio
¿En dónde?
En la casa de mi hija Gisela Lerner Reis
La foto es una nieta de mi hija
Anita Reis
y dos nietas de Yitzhak Meier Reis
¿Cómo se llama ella?
Se llama
Estela
Estela Rubinstein
¿Cuándo fue tomada esa foto?
La foto es
yo creo que hay como nueve meses que está tomada
Bueno, en este mes va a cumplir un año
Señor Yitzhak, me gustaría que le presentara a su familia
Mi familia, primero es
me siento mucho que no pude llegar a la hija de mayor, no sé el motivo por qué
Segundo
La hija, segunda
querida hija
con todo el cariño y con toda la alma
se llama Gisela Lerner Reis
¿Dónde está?
Gran profesional
gran médico
con gran respeto de su padre
y tal tal cosas que no quiero hablar mucho
porque no me da tiempo
Segunda hija mía
querida
Sonia Reis de Malta
una hija muy querida
es bien
hoy hija
bien muy madre
y todo
cosas perfectas
¿Orifio se quiere hablar?
Presénteme al resto de la familia
a ver, los viernes, los nietos
Sonia Lerner
Sonia Reis
y yo ya estoy un poco aborado
Mayor
yerno mío
es Jaime Lerner
no tengo palabras
palabras de él como se está pensando en la Torá
Kibbutz
of Boeing
respeto
yo soy padre
está dando su madre
un gran padre para su hija
y un gran esposo
un gran esposo para su
señora
y la única cosa que tengo a comentar
este hombre
¿a dónde viaja?
hoy les doy conmigo cinco semanas de viaje
siempre
contados y feliz
uno de las más grandes cosas que existe
ahorita
para entrar
mi querido yerno
doctor Samuel Malka
él todavía está haciendo las más grandes cosas del mundo
cuáles son las más grandes cosas del mundo
el Talmud dice así
no importa
cuando uno salva la vida de uno
como salvó el mundo, así dice el Talmud
segundo
un gran hijo
que él no se olvida
cada año
vuestro papá murió en San Cristóbal
y está entrado allá
es un gran cosa
que dice Torá
con respeto
que viaja
todo año para el cementerio
y está
viendo todo lo que está pasando allá
creció mucha hierba
él manda a limpiar
y siempre está pendiente
es una de las más grandes cosas
cosas
dice Talmud
cabet eivoin
es ley que dice Talmud
la historia dice
que después de la muerte
que uno da respeto
a su padre
que se pasa
cabet eivoin
ahorita
entramos
mi querido
nieto
Riquelme
como yo lo explico antes
es un muchachito
que siempre quiso saber de mi vida
con interés
qué pasó allá
qué pasó acá
él sabe más que yo y se acuerda más que yo
él me ofreció
una cosa en la vida
y él cumplió
yo pidió él el único título
y él me entregó tres títulos
ahorita no tengo palabras que decir
es bimbo hijo
parece que es bimbo novio y te presenta
novia de él
que poco yo conozco
no sé la historia de ella
muy temprano he hablado de la historia de ella
la historia ahorita viene
escrito
como Luciano Miguelá
de Estela Malka
puede ser que ella es una de esas mujeres
parecida a esta Malka
esta Malka
es una mujer del todo de la historia
conocida
que salvó mucho gente judía en la vida
segundo
mi nieto
segundo nieto Joy
está en California
con su esposo
con su nieto
bien buen muchacho
se casó para ley
y demás que yo se ayudo de él
segundo nieto, tercer nieto
que usted conozco
bien buen muchacho
médico
está tratando de llegar
y que yo se ayude de él
tercer nieto
¿cuál es tu nieto mío?
un chiquitito está sentado conmigo
que él me dio gran orgullo
que con 21 años él puede llegar
economista y más que economista
¿cómo se llama?
Meyer Malka de Reyes
nacido en Londres
de junio
¿y un nieto antes?
el nieto de antes
Robert, Leoni
y Same
Same se casó
no podía estar en el matrimonio
por
tal cosa
y ahorita
otro nieto
más grande vagamundo
Jonathan
está bien buen estudiante
está en tercer año de medicina
en segundo año de medicina
ya dijo bien
usted mire
yo quiero
que va a llegar
un gran médico como su papá
por su papá
no hay palabras
es un médico mundial
no puro el que yo dice
él puede demostrar
verbal y escrito
ahora díganos el mensaje
mensaje
yo voy a decir una frase
yo soy más rico del mundo
sentado
que yo podía llegar
a ese momento
explicarle mi historia
sobrevivir
yo creo que hay poca gente
y usted no va a contar más gente
mi sobrevivencia
a 44
8 de junio
mi querida mujer
no tengo palabras
para mis hijos
para mis
yernos
para mis nietos
decir cosas presencia
no tiene mucha calidad
de César
es mucho mejor
ahorita hay
una cosa
y aquí
está la novia
de mi nieto mayor
que yo quiero
pronto va a nacer
y que yo quiero
bien buena hora
va a nacer
por la ley
fecha saben ellos
yo no quería adelantar
saben ellos
y que yo deseo ellos
muchos suertes en la vida
señorita
mi mensaje
es así
hay
se va a hablar
se está pensando
de reyes
y pueblos
religiosos
y Dios
es el fundador
del mundo
los ángeles
preguntaron
como tú puedes demostrar
que tú eres fundador